E aí
[Música]
e o menino do Norte de João Galego de
boa vista ou estuda-se a delegacia um
bocadinho vai falar uma carinha suas
tardes que eu tenho da sua história do
meu passado da minha ligação como eu sou
muito ligada à família portanto eu vou
começar a contar um bocadinho da minha
história e desde os 9 anos para mim
é uma coisa boa estar aqui e poder
compartilhar tudo o que passou na minha
vida e o que vai se passando e tentar
ter essa pessoa positiva que tem de
transmitir coisas boas para todo mundo
para mim a razão Stark é precisamente
para ver se a cada canto do país nasce
mais uma lentamente e que se conseguimos
ter pessoas com alguma capacidade de a
diventare fazer coisas bonitas na nesse
país que é um país maravilhoso que nós
temos portanto eu queria começar assim
do Orelha muito especial tranquilo e
dizer às pessoas que normalmente na vida
tudo é possível quando a gente quer e
quando a gente consegue fato
lutar mas lutar mesmo lutar a série e
procurar todo o caminho partido podemos
chegar ao sucesso a minha vida começou
assim eu sou de uma família humilde do
Norte como é que eu disse João Galego eu
sou daquele menino que vendia pão
a partir dos 18 anos
fiz a minha primeira a minha experiência
inspirar para conhecer a capital que a
vila de sal-rei para quem conhece a Boa
Vista com 12 anos fui burro para vir
buscar farinha de trigo porque a minha
mãe tem um pequeno forno E aí era o
sustento da parte mundo toda nossa
família e nós ali começamos a levar o
dia levava o dia a dia volta de suor
Nivalda de outras e outras pequenas
coisas de p e para os meus pais linha
agricultura que está acontecendo aqui
nós
conseguimos criar condições para que nós
podemos sobreviver
e até que aos 18 anos
comecei depois de
tudo esse processo de de adolescência da
criança eu a primeira viagem Como eu
queria te ligar fui facto
para a Vila de sal-rei buscar o primeiro
saco de farinha de trigo montado num
burro se tinha que sair bem cedo porque
são três horas dá de viagens para vir e
três horas da tarde para voltar a pé e
ali começou aquela garra aquela vontade
de assumir a família de criar condições
de facto a minha família tivesse uma
vida mais mais Digno mais regular e foi
com uma vida mais mais feliz que nós
podemos ser mais felizes embora nós já
era uma família feliz da maneira que a
gente vivia Então tudo começou com uma
viagem por ser na gala onde é que está
aqui na minha tia veio e levou para
embarcar no barco de fazer alguma
passagem por exemplo para Europa Mas
normalmente em cima caríssimos barcos de
pesca e
quando eu fui embarcar facto não havia
eu não consegui fazer embarco para mim
foi uma desilusão vai estar grande e ali
comecei a desesperar e fica entrarem em
Pânico mas depois dos meus um Sangalo de
voltar para Cabo Verde se realmente
a minha volta não foi nada nada nada
para se foi uma volta uma viagem muito
complicado e com uma ideia
um pouco um pouco um pouco como é que
diz um pouco complicado porque voltava
de imigração e a vida era uma era pronto
vontade outra vez eu tinha aquela
desilusão de voltar outra vez para o
país e sem fazer nada sem dar o saldo
que normalmente os imigrantes e quando
sai e quer entrar mas na minha vida a
minha tia arrumação para Avenida E então
nessa nessa viagem eles eu arranjei já o
no Senegal estava se for Indaiá algumas
roupas usadas e alguns Plásticos e ele
trouxe comigo
é extremamente a turbulent Mas foi muito
complicado porque eu nasci não no norte
não tinha noção que se vierem Faro eram
Se fosse para mim o mundo tem a minha
mala minha mala e minha amiga Wanda ver
tudo isso aqui uma publicação foi dias
de estudo publicado aqui na praia depois
consegui ultrapassar foi a a Boavista
cheguei com essa essa material de altura
as coisas eram mais fácil
que começamos a vender as roupas o Plast
e eu estou a falar de Boa Vista que não
havia transposto de ir na altura 45
carros do ligado instituições do governo
e ele a minha a minha vai começou a
vender aquele fomos a fundo Figueira eu
começar que na Costa do lado pro outro
tentar vender e ali vi no fundo do túnel
uma oportunidade de fazer alguma coisa
então vim para casa falei com a minha
mãe a insistência de negócio meu pai não
queria dizer não não é possível é porque
eu nossa casa já tinha nos vídeos curtos
na altura Não era como agora a vida e os
cursos aí agora se ligasse uma doença
era um que era um de que maneira se
tivesse um problema E aí onde é que nós
podemos voltar e E na verdade a minha
mãe achou a ideia muito interessante era
uma se vocês que gostavam de mim mesmo
não era uma pessoa só dissesse que tava
pessoal era bonita e assim o que hora
sempre mais bonita e portanto a minha
mãe tem essa essa maneira de ver para
mim e coma como tudo e então ele disse
nada não vamos vamos vamos dar os
músculos papai não que não responde ele
começou a minha história e pronto eu
comecei essas a viagem como a viagem que
eu fiz embora com essas tal roupas do
Forró Cangaia alguns plástico não
correram bem E então foi para o sábado
também cheguei no sábado e muito bem
recebido pelos amigos familiares onde
que eles disseram não aqui no sábado até
trabalho e vamos fazer o trabalho da
Lola já tinha a carta do condutor e tudo
não mas eu já tinha uma ideia fixa que
era um monte de negócio realmente fiz
mais uma viagem complicada com os meus
filhos dos cultos e mais alguma alguma
coisinha pulga para fazer essa viagem e
cheguei no celular na guiné-bissau
porque eu fui ver a guiné-bissau fui
para mim uma desilusão menor é porque
achei de dia e o meu Vou pensar na Galo
dia seguinte era bem cedo quando cheguei
no aeroporto se encontra aeroporto tudo
com velas não havia nem se dava para ver
o aeroporto fazer o seguinte fui uma
viagem extremamente outra vez um pouco
criava uma certa de ilusão você de fato
o que estás a pensar seria de facto o
bom para mim que eu queria mas pronto lá
existe fiz a primeira viagem as coisas
começaram a correr a correr bem com as
dificuldades no Boa Vista Transportes
ele fazia sempre
jogava normalmente com essa com os
negócios e eu fazia ser uma família a
norte e quem conhece rápido para jogar
até o ponto da Boa Vontade de muitas
vezes como tinha-se uma sapatilha eu
tinha que casar essa sapatilha para não
estragar e andar apê portanto era uma
maneira de Mas o que foi bom durante
todo esse tempo é que eu consegui juntar
a minha família por isso que a minha
base eu falo muito da Família a minha
base é a minha família foi foi a junto
com os meus pais com Deus irmãos está
que vamos conseguir e
na vida e coxas somos nós somos Então
ela e começamos a eu fiz as viagens
sábado para almoçar vender no sábado
vender na Boa Vista sempre como eu saco
na costa por um lado cria uma nova uma
nova maneira que uma das coisas que eu
gostei transmitir sobretudo por jovens
como é que sabe os negócios Acabei por
criar uma nova maneira de fazer as
pessoas convencer porque na altura não
havia tanta ligação com a com os
produtos análises aqui em Cabo Verde e
tinha algum problema é aceitar os frutos
que legal então eu começava a fazer uma
oração a orar disseram sua história eu
tenho esse produto porém não sei que nós
que você compra se gostares e se você
não gostar pode me chamar qualquer hora
que vem cá buscar ou então não paga e
não sei mais o que eu comecei a dizer
assim essa com essa visão e pronto
começamos a criar clientes Natura
a Natura está me já a gente é comigo e
muito o sal comecei a comprar lagosta
comprar um negócio depois disso as
nossas começa numa oportunidade porque
como eu ficava com muito tempo a gente
ia tirar De La Paz para levar para o
estado para vender e uma numa dessas
viagens para tirar lá pa encontrei ali
umas cedo e gostam das gatas com aquelas
caixas de madeira e os pescadores
viraram a quem comprar e desceu como
eles não se está a brincar por uns ela
pode comprar toda ela gosta disso não
não não há problemas não posso comprar e
eles não não e depois vender não agora
então negócio já começou a dizer um
negócio provavelmente ele vai pagar eu
confirmei com eles estamos os preços mas
não via telemóvel eu fiz das gata para
fungos Figueira que são país sete
quilómetros a pé foi Telefonar era um
telefone que tinha no norte era só na
fogueira liguei para assistir à TV
perguntar a seguinte cidades a dar um
negócio que era o avião de seis ou sete
lugares no teu erro Nessa altura e os
senhores não não problemas você onde
passageiro
do avião e o apresentador da Rocha E aí
que fiz a viagem
foi a sucesso cheguei no aeroporto do
sal O pessoal estava ligada a TAP no
cantinho vocês ela gosta de Boa Vista e
comecei a linha de ganhar clientes a
falar que de fato não havia problema que
podia arranjar mais lagosta e no mesmo
avião que eu fui voltei com mais ou
menos mais dois ou três imigrantes e
cheguei vim a tudo conteúdo que vende
receber meu dinheiro e cheguei no
aeroporto rabbid com meu dinheirinho no
bolso Era quatro mais - 44 idade da
tarde não tinha Transportes a correr do
João Galego 25 Km até duas horas
tranquilo tomar meu bem no dia seguinte
eu estava outra vez na na minha resgata
a buscar mais lá gosta agora a controlar
e já começar a agilizar os negócios
potente isso eu não vou falar muito
porque senão
nadar dessas coisas pronto eu eu quero
facto de falar de coisas boas e então
ali fui o que provavelmente uma praça de
identidade para explicar eu vou ficar
nessa parte por aqui porque depois veio
a boticária
aquela orçamento depois de vender as
roupas começar a ter muitos clientes
pouco sal estava estava na top de tinha
o aeroporto e ainda as empresas de sal
tá falando pedra de uma ver ainda formei
na funcionária da cintura e então
começamos a vender um sala e a boca a
boca começou a passar a tem um primo de
plantão de Boa Vista e não sabem então
nós começamos a ter algum sucesso de
vendas então acabamos por abrir a
Boticário que foi uma das coisas que eu
fiz mais queridas e longe de tudo que a
gente ficava num sítio e todo o mundo
passava altura as pessoas de Tap do
estivesse vestiu muito bem tudo eu tudo
com sapatos top gente serviço a rua toda
e a comprar na Ribeira Funda onde é que
eu fiz a Boutique e as fazia porque o
que algum então ali começamos a ter
algum peso no mercado um mês depois
as coisas correram muito bem muito bem
bons o que as pessoas falam muito da
pizza e eu já passei por muitas
dificuldades em conseguir ultrapassar eu
só vou dar esse detalhe pessoas ter uma
ideia fui a primeira que nós começamos a
a contratar impressa é pessoas de pesca
da carpa nos para fazer Providência
processo associado a criaram as
condições de vida melhor para os
pescadores visto que a gente já estava
ganhar muito dinheiro com eles e o azar
com os tipos veio a cola não sei se as
pessoas lembro aqui e nós começamos a
pescar em outubro acabou a venda de
lagosta e nós tinha um contrato assinado
com eles a gente quer pagar eu sempre
quis ficar não ficava pensar o meu Deus
espera com a gente não pesco eu havia só
telefone não ia me pagar hoje buscaram
200 quilos de pescado 150 quilos e Nós
entramos sempre eu a minha esposa
trabalhava no banco e apanhar o dinheiro
no banco da gente tinha Fazia tudo de
boutique e de outras coisas para pagar
faturas pescadores e ficamos sair com
uma quantidade de agosto impressionado
no céu marca eram as câmeras grandes e
não eu vou fazer meu Deus de repente
chegou o mês de março abril ligaram para
mim um dia
avisamos lagosta
eu fui levar os primeiros 10 kilos
Ah pois mais tarde foi levar mais 15
quilos depois avião só tens que
apresenta altura soltinho Belo Horizonte
tem uma mesa e começar a lhe pedir a da
tripulação Da TAP na que nós fornecemos
ela gosta todos os militares na altura
fazer um serviço para São Tomé para
Angola passava aqui a única coisa que
nós teríamos aqui que era prenda ela
gosta nós queremos mais caixinhas não
via coca-cola era tudo narrado a linha a
mão mas não tinha fazer aquilo muito bem
feito para estar que sabia que uma
prenda de como uma prenda para pessoas
entregar as se elas companhias todas que
de que estavam aqui a união O que é que
vou levar também liga para mim tivemos
que as lagostas 2 kilos em 3 quilos e
Nós criamos uma temos nenhum dos meus
irmãos a gente que conhecia as pessoas
pessoas Telefonar midsole o cliente vai
com calça branca fato azul no cliente
veio na semana e nós tinha o habilidade
e os meus irmãos no aeroporto do sado
tentar localizar pelo menos
30 40 às vezes até mais pessoas que
entregar 2 kilos em 5 kg o tempo passava
a noite toda a fazer isso Então esse foi
uma parte que tentava falar de lagosta
que a gente vendia e depois começamos a
vender a lógica na visão de nós temos
uma coisa tão rápida no verão ficamos
com todo dinheiro
e na altura não tinha essa mania de
investir não conseguiu quer fazer com o
dinheiro então resolvemos entrar na
frente da casa com esse dinheiro as suas
com sabão eu já tinha tido uma lata
velha tudo na mão que tinha comprado a
tinha tido uma convidada que só lá no
sábado era vai pedir um esse carro na
altura do Gere eu fiz aluguer lavar e
depois fica ele podia ter um cuidado com
um banho os três primeiros nos últimos
dois parece um crime e do atriz disse
que foi graves uma altura que nós
podemos gastar neste momento se menos eu
acho que é uma empresa que militar gente
conhece a maior empresa de rent-a-car
tivesse país e ali começamos a dar
Passos porque pronto o meu tempo Acho
que é um bocadinho curso eu pude ver se
eu consigo desligar um pouco tudo de
rent-a-car entre devemos Oi para o hotel
começamos com 3 quartos na Boa Vista e
ali dos três quartos nós temos fazer
transferir excursão porque ninguém podia
buscar no aeroporto e nós fomos os
primeiros ali também nasceu aquele mito
também eu acho também que é um dos
fundos imobiliários um dos grandes
operadores nós temos com os autocarros e
tudo que as pessoas conhecem na Boa
Vista pintar de ver e dos hotéis como
três quartos nós conseguimos chegar onde
é que estamos a hoje estamos no sábado
estamos na Boa Vista mas agora São
Vicente na rent-a-car tamos na praia e
que normalmente temos o que me deixa
mais feliz e como ajudamos uma
quantidade de voz trabalho razoável e a
minha atenção a minha ilusão é de facto
da minha do meu sonho é de facto de cada
vez criar mais postos de trabalho e
dizer as pessoas para evitar esse país
maravilhoso que nós temos nós temos a
sorte ter um país que as pessoas pagam
para pedir carro visitar porque é que
nós não podemos pensar de maneira
positiva porque é que nós não podemos
ver as coisas boas que nesse país hoje e
eu não aceito eu não quero buscar
variados continuar dizer isso somos um
país porção somos um país rico agora
precisamos trabalhar eu estou a lidar
uma pequena uma pedra testemunha porque
são 40 anos de muito trabalho de muita
luta eu gostaria de passar uma mensagem
positiva uma mensagem de força de
alegria de sobretudo da seriedade da
honestidade de respeito porque as
pessoas não transformam com dinheiro as
pessoas transformam com honestidade com
palavra com respeito aquilo lá
e assim podemos de facto criar um Cabo
Verde melhor e eu deixava um apelo a
todos os empresários para fazer o que
nós estamos a fazer hoje eu estou a
gastar nesse momento todo o dinheiro que
ele tem para ajudar os outros
cabo-verdianos que não tem portanto eu
também queria dizer isso para para que
as pessoas podem entender criando postos
de trabalho criando que queres nesse
país o dinheiro volta outra vez nós
vamos ganhar dinheiro outra vez agora se
não tiver mais trabalhos não tiver mais
riqueza de um país nós vamos ganhar
dinheiro eu gostaria de deixar também
uma palavra e também dizer às pessoas
porque é que eu estou aqui eu estou aqui
com ele disse no princípio porque eu
gostaria mesmo depois de fazer dar essa
essa essa testemunha um pouca na outra
maneira que eu queria porque o tempo é
limitado mas eu gostaria pelo menos em
cada canto cabelo pessoa que estava na a
trocando fazer a questão de pesquisar
mais é fácil chegar no João Galego para
saber onde é que eu saí para ver que é
para a possibilidades nesse país ter
muito menos m Ou pelo menos muito
maneiro António Covas pessoas conhece e
a gente conseguir avançar e tentar levar
as país para um bom caminho eu acredito
nesse país Eu só deixo o meu dinheiro em
Cabo Verde e ele deixa eu só fiz isto
desinvestimento nunca vou parar de
trabalhar vou trabalhar até morrer
porque eu gosto de festa isso é
maravilhosa assim esse é o nosso por
isso que eu gostaria que todos
começassem a partir dos mudar esse ideia
eu queria ver mais gente a criar essa
possibilidade EA dar chance para ficar
todo mundo pode ser feliz nessa cabeça
tá bom ó